Hello there!
A blog post controversially entitled
“Please Commit More Blatant Academic Fraud”
has been making waves in the Machine Learning
/ AI community… on Twitter.
And Reddit.
Especially because it is the cry of a fellow
PhD student, you know, not a renowned professor
or anything,
Ms. Coffee Bean proposed to give this blog
post a read and to comment on it in this video.
So what is this all about?
The blog post starts directly with mentioning
what event even triggered it’s writing:
It is this viewpoint by a renowned personality
in the Machine Learning community, Prof. Michael
L. Littman.
This piece is reporting about a method of
cheating the peer review called "collusion
rings".
And bear with Ms. Coffee Bean, because we
know that you know that peer review is broken,
but this is like…
organized fraud.
It’s the collusion ring mafia breaking the
already broken review system.
Okay, so what’s the deal, how does this
work?
Pay close attention, because this is so intricate,
that Ms. Coffee Bean honestly wonders how
somebody can even come up with this.
Well, it’s smart people working in AI after
all.
The scheme works like this:
First, a group of colluding authors…
[Google searching]
You’re not a native English speaker Ms.
Coffee Bean, are you?
"collusion": "secret or illegal cooperation
or conspiracy in order to deceive others".
So we’re on that level now!
Ok, so a group of colluding authors writes
and submits papers to a conference.
That’s something even non-crooked authors
would do.
But then they share amongst themselves the
title of the papers,
which is against the rules, because it ruins
anonymity in peer reviewing.
Then, these colluders hide their conflict
of interest.
So they hide anything that could tell a meta-reviewer
that they might know the other authors.
How?
Well...
With duplicate accounts.
And interestingly enough, there was no way
to tell these are fake accounts!?
Well, not really, not in a field growing and
growing,
like Machine Learning does currently.
Exponentially!
So, the collusion ring fellowship bids for
the papers, which means that in the phase
where reviewers can tell which papers they
would like to review,
they choose the papers from their collusion
ring... fellowship.
And hopefully they get the papers of their
fellows, write positive reviews to them and
even lobby through back channels to change
the opinions of other reviewers!?
Or send threats if others feel like something
is fishy!?
Wow.
And the most crazy part is:
This scheme seemed to work in this discovered
case, but who knows how many cases go undetected?
The viewpoint piece is not disclosing specific
details, just to respect the fraudulent researchers
and not disclose information that might identify
them.
Oh, it’s anonymous peer review after all!
[mip]
But thinking how important conference acceptances
are for anyone, and especially for PhD students
who do not have the safety of a professorship
or tenure and need to find a next job after
their PhD, it is no wonder it hit Jacob Buckman
– who is a PhD student – so badly, that
it motivated him to write this blog post which
we finally come to discuss right now!
Independently on whether you agree with him
or not, you are free to form your own opinions.
But we think we all can agree that this is
a very grim viewpoint adopted here.
His main point is that this example highlighted
by Prof. Littman might be one of the worst
cases of fraud,
but that there is a more “mundane, and day-to-day
fraud” that is happening regularly.
But if the “day-to-day fraud” would be
more blatant, like the “fellowship of the
collusion rings”-fraud we saw earlier, a
change in the field’s organization might
come sooner, because then everybody would
see how wrong everything is and fight for
a change.
So what exactly is wrong in ML?
Examples of this “day-to-day fraud” are:
We cite: “Trying that shiny new algorithm
out on a couple dozen seeds, and then only
reporting the best few."
Well...
That's happening.
For sure.
"Running a big hyperparameter sweep on your
proposed approach but using the defaults for
the baseline."
Who even spends so much time tuning the baselines
and some of the baselines are not even tunable
because the code was not released or it's
not working for some reason.
"Cherry-picking examples where your model
looks good, or cherry-picking whole datasets
to test on, where you’ve confirmed your
model’s advantage."
Mhmm..
"Making up new problem settings, new datasets,
new objectives in order to claim victory on
an empty playing field.”
Well, this one is a little against the goal
of research, and has been discussed on Twitter.
And Ms. Coffee Bean also thinks it's a little
unfair, because even if sometimes you don’t
see the impact of a new problem or application,
there are people who genuinely need that,
it’s not necessarily that an author is creating
a problem just for the sake of having one.
Okay then “Proclaiming that your work is
a “promising first step” in your introduction,
despite being fully aware that nobody will
ever build on it.
Submitting a paper to a conference because
it’s got a decent shot at acceptance and
you don’t want the time you spent on it
go to waste, even though you’ve since realized
that the core ideas aren’t quite correct.”
This last point is very heavily weighing on
PhD students with limited time to get to hold
on to something.
Especially if things are not going so well,
there is a lot of pressure to still make a
publication out of that.
This is why, Ms. Coffee bean salutes initiatives
that highlight negative results in the field,
like this one here, making it unnecessary
to hide that results are bad and to mask them
as actually good.
Okay, so these are the problems, and Jacob
Buckman (Ms. Coffee Bean, is this how the
name is really pronounced?)
So Jacob writes that the even bigger problem
is that these points are subtle and easy to
dismiss by saying something like the hyperparameters
were just forgotten, or that something is
just a bug,
therefore nobody can propose hard punishments
for this.
And Ms. Coffee Bean’s “rule of cheating”
says that if one does it, the next does it,
until most of people do it just to keep up
with everybody who is cheating already.
Ok, but the next point in the post is saying
that everybody is complicit, because nobody
acknowledges the existence of this subtle
fraud.
And there are some reasons to this, especially
those people benefiting from the current state
of affairs, do not want a new organization
of things.
That's easy to understand.
But this point falls rather short in the blog
post, Ms. Coffee Bean,doesn’t it?
Because this point implies a little that everybody
knows about these problems.
But do they?
Here we might have to split between people
who do know, and people who don’t.
There are some examples of people who don’t:
My experience from teaching students at my
university is that people are not born knowing
about these problems, but they have to learn
about them, one by one.
Especially at Bachelors and even Masters level,
it is very common that research papers are
read like the Bible.
Things in it must be true if it stands in
a paper, it was accepted at a conference!
Someone even formatted it nicely with LaTeX!
Critical thinking is something that one has
to learn.
Another group of people who do not know about
the problems, but have critical thinking are
experienced researchers.
Critical thinking applies only to their fields
of expertise, because on some topics they
do not know enough to even think critically!
And you know, if you are just visiting a field
or topic, you will also not invest the time
necessary to learn ALL things.
You're just passing by!
Okay, but even if Ms. Coffee Bean does not
agree with distributing the blame so widely,
she does agree that there are not many people
doing something effectively about the problems,
even if there are some attempts at it.
Some attempts were highlighted in this tweet
by Anna Rogers, linked in the description
below.
Check it out!
But what to do about these problems int the
proposal of this blog post?
Well, the proposal is to make academic fraud
blatant, visible to everyone but especially
unacceptable so that one cannot merely stand
aside doing nothing about it.
“Make blatant fraud, aggressive fraud.
Form more collusion rings!” like the ones
we have seen in the beginning.
This is the grim call of a PhD student and
this has to be taken seriously.
He even makes an analogy to chemotherapy;
unpleasant, but effective, even if it destroys
the field entirely.
So Ms. Coffee Bean’s question is, do we
want this to happen to the Machine Learning
community?
Do we want to kill it to hope it rises again
but without all problems from before?
Well, as someone originally from a country
that has recently seen this kind of treatment
in a bloody revolution, but where at the end
all the old problems came back in a slightly
different form, this time just dressed as
capitalism instead of socialism, I am very
distrustful that even if everybody would follow
this advice, this would really cure the problems.
Because who would follow this advice?
Who would volunteer to make these blatant
frauds?
Anyone willing to put their academic integrity
on the line?
No?
Anyone?
Do not get us wrong here, I as a fellow PhD
student, love the revolutionary, angry tone
of this blog post, I feel with it.
It is great that these to pics come up as
a discussion and here we cheer for Jacob who
wrote it.
[cheering]
But Ms. Coffee Bean takes me down from my
angry PhD frustrations and tells me to think
more constructively and propose a solution
that not only has a chance to work, but one
that people are even willing to apply in the
first place.
So here it is, the long-awaited solution to
all problems in ML publications, reviewing
and the collusion ring cancer!
Are you ready?
[Flat line]
Sorry, the broadcast was interrupted, just
like during the Romanian revolution in 1989.
Ah, that's the reference probably not many
viewers will get!
Sorry!
Okay, Ms. Coffee Bean has three proposals.
They are not fully fleshed out, that might
possibly become a future video…
I don't know!
Here they are, in their current form:
The first thing is education.
As previously said from my teaching experience,
there is a lot of work needed to teach students
(and people in general), that just because
something is written in a conference format,
or is, I don't know: in a nice video, does
not make it true.
Critical thinking (also useful for reviewing)
must be learnt and practiced, not taken for
granted.
And the best thing that could happen out of
this, is that critically thinking students
will take over, when the dinosaurs conducting
science badly, will disappear.
I know, it is a long-time investment, nobody
likes these.
The second proposal is: Discussion.
Putting these issues into public view and
to everyone’s discussion, exactly like this
post does.
Ms. Coffee Bean loves it how it highlights
these subtle problems and puts them into broad
daylight for people all around the world to
discuss about this on Twitter or Reddit.
And the final idea is…
In-depth and independent science journalism
in Machine Learning.
Writers, bloggers, or ahem, even people with
YouTube channels to get monthly a random subset
of all new publications to critically assess,
publicly review and simultaneously communicate
to non-experts what the field is up to.
The upside: Even if not all publications from
that month will fall into this random selective
lottery,
there is a chance that when an author publishes
a paper, that paper will be randomly chosen
for the public review process.
It’s enough of an incentive for the authors
to make their paper waterproof, especially
knowing that a well-known critic will say
something about your paper.
Of course one has to take care that these
public reviewers do not have any conflict
of interest or that they have to be afraid
that their own papers would get a negative
review, so what Ms. Coffee Bean is imagining
is this as a full-time job for them, like
literary critics for novels or for poetry.
And of course, these journalists / reviewers
should be well paid, perhaps by someone with
a lot of money caring for a healthy and diverse
field;
to create perhaps a common fond, where any
ML benefactor could contribute to.
What do you think of this?
Of course, these are just some suggestions
Ms. Coffee Bean thought of just now.
So let’s discuss: Write in the comments,
tweet or perhaps write a position paper for
the next conference.
How should we improve the state of publication
in AI?
Perhaps without killing it first, ok?
So tell us what do you think.
Ms. Coffee Bean will devour your comments.
Even if the state of ML academia is not healthy,
we hope you are.
Stay safe.
Okay bye!